I just have to ask you how much has
changed in your life in your career in
two years since a separation was honored
at the Oscars
you got the softening film of in
monopoly right follow TK but as female
truth ie of the nasty booty ho demoted
in some shitty reality rocked out to a
zindagi on the making of this film
occurred so soon after the ending of a
separation and the receiving of the
awards that frankly I myself don't feel
that I know what has changed in my life
my life to give hundred eighty hjx on
national curriculum being whenever
studying the stuff before a separation
had even screened anywhere I began to
think about and write this story
she isn't a shock some time for Haley
tough over teachers my cabinet to fall
off but it is in the aged about my
private life too there were not many
repercussions or changes as a result of
these events but in my public social
life there were some noticeable changes
I wanted to ask you about the decision
to shoot this outside of Iran in France
and in French which is if my information
is correct the language that you don't
speak and so that's obviously in an
unusual situation to have to direct the
movie in a foreign language for for you
for the filmmaker and so I just why was
it that that's the way you decided to do
it
master given task me give some criticism
they still would come on big ticket
coach office as I mentioned when I
decided to make this film it was the
story that came and found me and it was
the story that dictated where I had to
make that fun I'm molecular Samba samba
heat shoe fake name account I'm Victor
McCallum kill in Europe was okay mine's
a bond I collect at home on a mission a
son when I was thinking about the story
I in no way thought to myself this is a
major hurdle the fact that I don't speak
the language of these characters
Fusco maybe some you know out of a
business I shall repair to baby now in
Tamil Minnesota shot when I was running
it if they would I simply wanted to
write this screenplay make the film and
see it on a screen this preoccupied me
every moment night and day just what
you're telling me now is that one is
when the screenplay was completed that I
had to confront the fact that a major
problem existed called language that is
I can you know he paid Okinawa in quinta
as image github issue a visa give any
man I attempted however to find a way
that this instead of a problem could
turn into a unique and original event
for me Karim Allah from disappearances
in the caramel is often Fein
consequently I went and lived in France
for two years to make this film the ruse
parties sorry wrong we'd have to have a
sign canonized equation wheat and every
day for hours I would walk along with
streets of Paris and attempt to
penetrate that environment but
occasionally is a bonne journee me to
need disturbing I'm gonna go me koni
Bank epiphany nation there are times of
when because you don't speak a language
you look at people more in order to try
and comprehend things better I become an
cascada meaning care Moebius turbo
frequently at that amici's rest I
reserve on BOM dia won't arraign makan
embodies a banya crush a well Sudhir to
what he was in my experience that I
gained we mistakenly imagined that it is
through language that we can communicate
with each other whereas in fact language
is only one aspect of the ways in which
we communicate how much is Bob Lazar
after service initially showed by
shakiness and reality everything began
before going on set and beginning
production must give him neither nervous
tom boy you can officially can adopt to
Karen and wife Erin see after I'd
written this
play began to adapt it into French with
someone
Cassie would camp out fr see me Denise
this was someone who spoke a new both
Persian extremely well and French do
mock could catch it mo behind again in
Ruby Ference adapted Connie I took us
two months working together to turn the
screenplay into French Hameed you look
horrible man MIG of K children calamari
and Hokkaido my channel today key K
Mitra and hope can achieve a rosy chance
a fever bihamdihi kamikaze my Manito GK
and they would tell me she she would
tell me every single line of dialogue
and why she made the choices she made
and we worked very slowly on only a few
pages each day the bathroom no
inoculation my babe
ference a viewing Behunin as room
jean-claude carrière begin kumamon
efferent psych eval named Akane and once
the screenplay was completed we asked
several French readers to look at it
including jean-claude carrière to tell
us where the dialogues might need work
and might not seem credible to a French
person well I do that we go jean-claude
asked if you know whom okay
he choice nice give it to my concubine I
was going the inference that we financed
avatar I wish they showed it and in fact
once jean-claude Carriere had read he
indicated that there was no changes to
be made that dialogues really seemed
very French more French than the French
in German family them in musketeer would
never be maternal bone in Saban cannot
be and that was when I realized that
this problem had been dissolved and that
we'd come to terms I had come to terms
with this language sorry Sonya guru
Hermitage understand key on hanbok guru
during on production on sunset I had a
group of interpreters who were my
communicators with the group a neutron
bazooka of humanity magenta bazooka man
who stole me to nest and she additional
comic-con akira adorable
but because the actors had seen my
previous films and knew my style of
acting they too were able to help and
find the right waiter
let's go so let's talk about bérénice
Bejo who is the star of this film and
people probably know her most of all
from the artists from before even if
they didn't hear her in that and so I
just wonder how you decided to ask her
to play the part do tacos aesthetically
was overly stir to specific
characteristics that she has bill money
a capacity attack speed how actually it
was gonna maybe mean this isn't a sneaky
McCallum sampati got it she has a
quality when you see her playing
whatever part on the screen a kind of
warmth and sympathy that brings the
audience close to her they usually
cherish a be here shock theater you want
to feel my problem I understand but
again I could feel my happening and to
only supposed to get a human emotion
cochlea fashion and in some ways her
features her face resembled those of
actresses that I have worked with in
other films of mine she doesn't seem
very far from that look people have
observed that it seems that you are
particularly interested in sort of the
family dynamics the things that go on
behind closed doors within families
whether it's in France or Iran or
wherever
Khulna Taganrog boutique in sundar
Robert Ivanova Dickey the oldest
relationship that exists for human
beings as the family as much get
Michelle to touch the knee repeater
which were thirsty from ever since man
has existed this relationship has also
existed valium or Scottish I wish it was
a tiring muscular tea but there are
problems that arise within it appear to
be fresh each time in God kahan Robert
Enke should we say
you know way through the Watersafe
machine as the each time a relationship
begins in you you set the mileage
counter to zero the other I mean but on
that whole pattern of them being Roberto
giants of it and that's why really
delving into these relationships is of
interest to me
hanno about a Masonic Kuchiki as you h
know it was looked at for me family is a
small sampling of a much larger grouping
of economy shame but she's making a - no
it was a terrible - the papers and on
the premise of dealing with the
relationships between members of a
family one can discover much more
profound truths about much greater
societal issues he in Kosciusko Jamaat
back to Brazil gas that will be a fossil
you may know the issue where someone
comes from appears to form a dark
dividing line among human beings beings
well we're talking about what the whole
cd-rom shot Vienna what I believe is
that human beings really resemble each
other
enormous ly as abortion firing an
economy that is so different about
champion really doesn't matter where it
is they're from in there
sentimental landscape in their emotions
they resemble each other tremendously
valuable resuscitation vampire mokona
but the way in which they express those
emotions there is a difference
Hameed read on your Jimeno Adam home
mozzie ish margin usually all human
beings all over the world experienced
the taste of love the same way annoying
a brother spent a year making asean up
or he can scares me did his mucus guys
able to come you found the way of
expressing it is different for someone
who comes from asia someone who comes
from the Middle East or someone who
comes from a AMERICA AMERICA